alexis bonjour très heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin une nouvelle fois
dans la matinale de rtl france alors ce
troisième confinement est ce que c'est
possible
c'est tout à fait possible tout est
possible dans cette crise on aura
décidément tout vu rappelons-nous c'est
l'anniversaire à nant quasiment à un
jour près de la déclaration d' agnès
buzyn alors ministre de la santé qui
disait que ce virus avait très peu de
chances de circuler sur le territoire
français où on a connu un confinement de
confinement des couvre-feux plainds
amendes pour non-respect de l'auto
attestation de sortie donc un troisième
confinement serait tout à fait possible
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils essaient
garda d'amener en douceur l'exécutif
personne n'est dupe on attend quasiment
cette annonce depuis le début janvier
puisque on nous parlait de l'effet des
fêtes nathan parle de l'effet galette de
l'effet épiphanie à savoir est ce que
les français avec ce nouveau variant
réglait vont vont se contaminer
davantage
alors on scrute la courbe cette petite
courbe de grenat virus savoir où ça va s
que ça va encore nous emmener à nous
enfermer pendant un mois comme en mars
2002 20 ce qui est incroyable c'est que
finalement on ne sait pas trop où va ce
gouvernement comme d'habitude la gestion
est opaque
elle est infantilisante puisqu'on nous
prend un peu pour des idiots à savoir
plutôt que d'annoncer bien en amont
qu'il va falloir fermer mais on continue
avec comme d'habitude des mesures qui
n'ont aucun sens le conseil scientifique
qui maintenant recommande de ne plus
parler dans le métro et pourtant les
écoles restent ouvertes avec des enfants
qui n'ont pas forcément des masses des
masques en tissu on nous dit de mettre
des ffp2 on a vu dès que lors des soldes
bien plus compact que les que qu'on peut
voir devant les remontées mécaniques de
ski par exemple
donc voilà tout et comme d'habitude on
n'y comprend rien mais c'est une
stratégie du désordre in assumé par le
gouvernement qui commence à peser lourd
avec toujours cette idée de critiquer
les comportements personnels des
français et là ça commence vraiment à
bien faire les français semblent tout de
même résigné
1 alors est ce que les français sont
résignés je ne crois pas on voit déjà
poindre ici et là des hashtags je ne me
confinerait pas donc ça suffit
ce troisième confinement plus personne
ne veut en réalité on voit aussi des
appels à la désobéissance civile qui
sont en france mais aussi à
l'international la journée du 1er
février qui serait une journée de
désobéissance mondiale par rapport à
cette crise de coronavirus et puis on
voit dans des pays voisins les pays bas
par exemple des émeutes importante parce
que le pays voudrait mettre des mesures
restrictives comme le couvre-feu alors
que ce pays là ne connaissait pas encore
ce type de mesures le problème vous le
voyez bien dans ces mesures prises par
les gouvernements qui sont attentatoires
aux libertés
c'est que plus on commence loin dans le
curseur plus on continue finalement à
empêcher les gens de vivre
or là maintenant le problème devient
critique il est économique l'espagne
disait ouvertement que économiquement le
pays ne pouvait se permettre à nouveau
confinement
c'est sans doute aussi un peu le cas de
la france parce que cette crise
sanitaire elle est devenue maintenant
une crise sociale et une crise
économique majeure
donc est-ce qu'elle confinement est
possible déjà c'est la première question
économiquement
la réponse est à quel prix prix
psychologique on commence enfin à parler
du poids psychologique sur les plus
jeunes mais aussi sur tous les
commerçants le nombre de suscite qui ne
fait qu'augmenter de restaurateurs de
petits commerçants et d'autres aussi le
risque de faillite évident et la dette
ne résoudra pas tout donc aujourd'hui
maintenant peu importe les pirouettes
sémantiques du gouvernement il semble
que ce confinement même s'il devait
arriver ne sera pas du tout vécu comme
les autres et risque d'être extrêmement
contestée alors il ya quelques mois on
attendait un vaccin on se disait voilà
le confinement tout ça sera terminé ce
n'est pas le cas on en est ou de la
vaccination alors sur la vaccination
jean castex s'est félicité du 1 million
de vaccinés comme il dit alors il faut
relativiser c'est un million de
personnes qui ont reçu la première dose
du vaccin pour être vacciné il faut deux
doses à 21 jours d'intervalle donc là on
a un million de personnes qui ont reçu
une dose d'un vaccin vaccin qui commence
à être contesté également dans le
pourcentage de ré de réussite de
protection ont parlé de 95%
de fiabilité de ce vaccin lors des tests
or certaines études qui commence à
monter par seulement 2 29% de 40% et
puis le problème des variants les
variants à rive sud africains brésiliens
variant angles est hélas certains
vaccins seraient inefficaces face aux
variants on a même monsieur delfraissy
qui est au conseil scientifique qui nous
dit que ce virus est très intelligent
qu'il est diabolique parce qu'ils se
mettent à muter qu'il comprend comment
continuer sa propagation
eh bien oui monsieur delfraissy apprend
ce qu est un virus sa couronne comme les
virus de la grippe ça des virus qui mute
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer
leur propagation donc on est en train
d'attendre tout ce vaccin or les pays
qui vaccinent le plus et qui sont les
bons élèves de la vaccination les israël
la grande-bretagne et bien confine
également et puis la vaccination
n'empêche pas les gestes barrière ni le
masque ni la propagation du virus donc
solution miracle du rex ainsi elle
permet certes d'éviter les formes graves
et de limiter dans certaines populations
à cible la propagation du virus n'est
pas une solution miracle et il va
falloir trouver comment relancer la vie
relancer l'économie et arrêter cette
politique du stop and go qui a des
conséquences catastrophiques
psychologique sociale et économique est
là les gouvernements semblent bien
désemparé si le vaccin ne suffit plus
merci beaucoup alexis poulain pour votre
édito ce matin dans la matinale à lundi
prochain